il
y'a plus de musique à la radio tabarja
plus y'a plus d'alcool dans les bistrots
d'abord ya plus
dans les bordels d'abord ya plus pauvres
y'a plus rien y'a plus rien n'y a fait
puisque ça vaut à part
presque pas
l'ayatollah
alors bien sûr ça n'engageait que
absolument que ça s'appelait cha cha cha
avec un jeunot sur le dernier char gros
jeu de nous ils vont etienne
accompagnées de son éternel compères gg
une des chansons gag de son nouvel album
sorti en ce début d'année le 5
une de ses chansons gags qui ont fait sa
renommée depuis qu'il est revenu au pays
dans le début des années 70 c'est un des
artistes de bretagne qui tourne le plus
non seulement en bretagne mais aussi
dans l'hexagone d'une manière générale
et même au delà
cinquième album d' yvan estienne de loin
le meilleur enregistré à ce jour le plus
abouti artistique dirais-je celui qui
réussit le mieux le subtil équilibre
entre les différents registres sur
lesquels ils vont etienne joue pour se
raconter car ne vous fiez pas uniquement
à cette chanson diack pour dire ah bah
yvon etienne c'est un rigolo c'est à un
gros rigolo parce qu'évidemment cet
argot rigolo par simplement d'ailleurs
sur les chansons dans la vie il aime
bien la bonne chère san antonio et puis
les calembours mais c'est aussi
quelqu'un d'autre par exemple c'est
souvent un temps de jeu dirais même à la
lueur de ce nouvel album plus souvent
attendre qu'un gros rigolo mais quand il
y as tendresse chez yvon etienne il ya
aussi malicieux
il suffirait de quoi grand chose car de
sega est à jour
mettre les pieds sur un bateau que je
m'en aille derrière l'eau suffirait
d'une belle histoire et de quelqu'un
populaire
je rassurais mais moi je la regrette
mais à ma manière est le pendant de voir
ailleurs si le camp est beau oui mais
c'est là qu'est la galère j'aime pas
partie j'aime pas partie il mais c'est
là qu'est la galère j'aime pas partie
chez lui revenir il suffirait d'une
chanson ou même d'un air d'accordéon peu
de bruit sur la mer un peu de mousse au
fond d'un verre rire généreux corsage ou
tout simplement d'une image que du jour
au lendemain je devienne un vrai mal
moi qui ne suis bien qu'à l'arrêt et
suis malade même sur le quai et mais
c'est là qu'est la grèce pas partir
j'aime pas partie mais cela qui est la
galère
j'aime pas partir gémir revenir
si les ports étaient de vrais pas
comme il y en a peut-être encore
pas des escales un point c'est tout
vulgaire lieu de rendez-vous dans des
trucs qui centre et vous dont la
pourriture où les chars ont pas le
dernier que dans le coup où l'on ne
pense qu'à boire un coup ou on proteste
en plein mois d'août parce que les
pêcheurs font dire mot oui mais c'est là
qu'est la galère je peux pas partir
j'aime pas partir mais c'est là qu'est
la galère j'aime pas partir j'ai mieux
revenir s'il y avait de vrais marins
il reste que quelques uns
et qui navigue pas dérapé avec la peep
et le ciré ils ne font que des ronds
dans l'eau par cotan et par mercer ou
qui mettent une casquette et laver un
pull un pantalon de toile sous prétexte
qu'un jour ils ont fait un kilomètre en
planche à voile
oui mais c'est là qu'est la guerre
j'aime pas partir j'aime pas partir
oui mais c'est là qu'est la galère
j'aime pas partir j'ai mieux revenir
pas partir j'aime pas partie oui mais
c'est là qu'est la galère j'aime pas
partir j'aime ironie oui mais c'est là
qu'est la galère
j'aime pas partir j'aime pas partie oui
mais c'est là qu'est la galère
j'aime pas partir j'aime mieux revenir
une des grandes réussites de ce dernier
album d' yvan estienne quête aussi à mon
sens dans le fait que ces différents
registres sur lesquels ils se racontent
les différentes couleurs qu'il utilise
dans ses chansons et bien sont servis
par un grand éclectisme musical
on passe ainsi allègrement et on viens
de l'entendre dire cha-cha-cha à une
bossa nova en passant par un bon vieux
rock'n'roll un blues une valse musette
ou un morceau de country c'est la
variété même à chaque fois
astucieusement fait et bien fait
et puis la force ultime d'yvon etienne à
mon sens toujours c'est de nous tromper
de nous surprendre entre deux gros éclat
de rire par exemple de nous asséner
quelque chose de sévères auxquelles on
ne s'attend pas quelque chose de grave
voire de sérieux ainsi sur son dernier
album une chanson du québécois sylvain
lelièvre prise rj arranger le chanteur
indigènes
le chanteur indigènes a sorti son
violent
115 ou sa bomba et son accordéon
enfin la panoplie des accessoires
ethniques qui pam les français et réveil
nous prédit
le chanteur indigènes
à commencer son jour
et les premiers accords
lola miaghri bravo
dans son harmonica ils soufflent jusqu'à
mordre et les droites son violon et
gardait le décor
bon
mais sous les projets
il est seul à savoir
il en met dedans
je sais son dernier soit
et
depuis il a compris
le commerce exotique où l'on vend en
bibelots son peuple et sa musique
le centre a dû jeunes et ni son numéro
jusqu'au bout sans au maire
une seule note un seul mot mais le
rideau tombé lorsque la foule paul lui
réclame à grands cris d'autres rythmes
créoles
le chanteur a les gènes
revient sur le plateau remercie son
public est seul à son micro
soudainement faty est tragiquement bm
se mettent à réciter ce singulier poèmes
on est toujours un coût
dire auprès de quelqu'un
le lensois territoire
retourney groupe cajun
je voulais sachant d
quel peut être le vôtre on est toujours
un peu
l'indigène d'amour
et puis l'homme en silence appuyer son
violon
son cazouls ça bombarde et son accordéon
on dit qu'il est parti retrouver sa
savane et qu'il vit là depuis tout seul
dans sa cabane
et
on est toujours un iroquois de quelqu'un
lens va qui est l'écho
redonnez
vous laisse à penser qu'elle peut être
le vôtre
on est toujours un peu
la dizaine d'années
bon